it attracts visitors from all over the
world everyone wants to have their
picture taken in front of it
the leaning tower is the quintessential
symbol of Pisa is that we think it's
great
I expected the tower to lean but I
didn't really expect it to lean that
much so it's fantastic
the leaning tower is actually the bell
tower of the Santa Maria Assunta
Cathedral at the time it was completed
in 1380 it was the largest Cathedral in
the Christian world in 1987 both the
tower and the cathedral were placed on
the UNESCO List of World Heritage Sites
the nearby baptismal chapel and cemetery
are also on the list all of the
buildings are made from white marble
construction of the tower itself began
in 1173 but just a few years later the
tower began to list because the
foundation had been built on soft clay
and it continued to subside for
centuries in 1990 the tower was closed
to the public for repairs the fact that
all they removed soil from underneath
the raised side of the tower mat allowed
them to straighten it a little and stop
it from tilting now the towers stable
and will likely stay that way for the
next 200 years uncle G
Sam okay dude up Italy no pollution time
when the tower reopened in 2001 the
local authorities put limits on the
number of visitors now only 40 people
are allowed in the tower at any one time
the view from the top is breathtaking
but he made a katana this is our first
visit I didn't know it tilted so much
when you climb up here it really throws
you off balance unbelievable England
south of the tower lies pieces historic
old town history
the Arno River flows through it in the
Middle Ages this part of the city was
home to the patrician classes
this brick Palazzo is home to Cafe de
Lucero founded in 1775 a local it
curricular Pisa this is the oldest
coffeehouse in Pisa famous philosophers
and writers like Carducci in Gujrat see
used to gather here it was a wonderful
period in Italian history university
students also made here pisa is one of
Italy's oldest university cities an
estimated 48,000 students are registered
here that's about half of Pease's
population there are three universities
in Pisa and most of their buildings are
located in the old town districts
lots of students choose Pisa because
it's a small city it's easy to get
around and it's not very expensive class
there are lots of bars and cafes lots of
young people study here sit down the ill
Monty know pizzeria is especially
popular with students it's the oldest in
the city the pizzas are stone baked and
affordable another popular item on the
menu is checchina a local bread made
from chickpea flour and roasted in olive
oil
the Palazzo della caravana was built in
the early 1560s since 1810 it has housed
the swollen or male superiority an elite
school in italy's university system a
number of its 5000 graduates have gone
on to greater things out of this small
group of students we have three Nobel
Prizes two presidents of the Italian
Republic several ministers Prime
Minister's the governor of the Italian
Central Bank and many other people that
have had quite an impact on the Italian
political economic and above all
cultural life pieces main shopping
street the Borgo stretto truly comes
alive in the evening hours bars and
restaurants here are packed with patrons
a Rowan crew when's its way down the
Arno River as our visit to Pisa draws to
a close a warm spring evening like this
is the perfect time to experience this
historic Italian city